- This is the "Turn Up" sandwich.
Like Little Jon, when he
wrote "Turn Down for What",
he wrote it based off of this
sandwich, this looks good.
(slow bass music)
I've never heard of Fat Sandwiches before.
- Sounds like the best sandwich ever.
- Better be stacked.
- Right?
- I feel like it's one
of those sandwiches,
where you should not
eat it like in public.
- I had some Pepto-Bismol
before this to prep my stomach.
- Smells like bread.
- Oh, shit, I lost a fry already.
- It's like the bread's breaking.
It can't handle the sandwich.
- They've put all the good things
in the world into one sandwich.
- Are students at Rutgers fatter than
the average university student?
- No, but they are drunker.
- Oh, they're drunker.
Oh, then this makes sense!
- I wanna be drunker,
is what I kinda want.
I would like to be drunker.
- This is so good.
- This is missing cheese.
- It is missing cheese.
- There's a mozzarella stick!
- There was a mozzarella stick in there?
- Disguised as chicken.
- Did we just like, inhale it and miss it?
- It needs more sauce.
- It really needs more sauce.
- I'm already full.
- Thank God you had that
marinara sauce with you.
- I mean, I don't go anywhere without it.
- If a friend wants to have heartburn
for the next seven or eight hours,
I would definitely recommend this.
- I ate everything, I don't
know where it even went.
- Ten out of ten, would eat again.
- It changed my life.
Forever.
- I ate it, I liked it, but that's
gonna give me a heart attack.
- It deserves the name "Fat Sandwich".
- It's a private affair, it's
a personal private affair.
- I made love to my sandwich,
like, yes, it was everything.
Like, I'm thinkin' about
how good it tastes.